[Music]
fifty years ago you couldn't hardly walk
through this place it was wall-to-wall
brush it wasn't any grass loving any
water nobody wanted
[Applause]
in the United States of America takes us
to well I was born you know how going
into poverty to be honest about it lived
out in the country
amongst the Amish people so I really got
my life example set for me by my own
mother that's where my love of the
natural world came from I've never
inherited a nickel that I inherited a
love the natural world in a respect
respect for when I get out of the
University I took a job so vacuum
cleaner shortage or I went into the
fast-food business I've teamed up with
the young man bill Church and it was
church's fried chicken and we built that
company up to over 1,600 stores and we
sold and with that capital I was able to
come here and begin my work on cela them
burger and preserve my objective was to
take the worst piece of land I could
possibly find in the hill country of
Texas and begin a process of restoration
that would change it back to be one of
the best and that has happened right
here
by habitat restoration by working with
Mother Nature and setting against her
and that's what we're all about 46 years
ago not a drop of water seven water
wells were drilled 500 foot deep not a
one produced any water the top 125 foot
of these hills looks like this said
words limestone when the driller drill
all goes well for me he said Bamberger
one place up here on the top my bit
dropped 40 foot he said you've got a
cavern under there's like an auditorium
the only thing about it was 46 years ago
it had no water in it it was dry it was
dry because the water that was coming in
was running off as opposed to sinking
him when I came here all the little
holes and all of that limestone or just
as dry as the one I'm holding in my hand
now what happened we replaced that
condition with this condition two and a
half years after we began the first
spring came to life
as we continued on another string showed
up we got up to where we had 11 where
the rider come back came out of all of
that holes in that perched aquifer like
that that's where it come from
if we stored in the first and all
because of one thing this one and I'm
telling you I'm going to show you the
greatest conservation tool ever made and
everything I talked about could not have
happened without grass the hill country
is discovered with woody species
primarily it's cedar we took out a great
portion of it here on the ranch we were
discovered with it we had no grass when
we took out the cedar and spread native
grass seeds and it began to grow
rainfall then percolated into the earth
because of the root system of grass
going down water percolates and it fills
up your aquifer until the aquifer is
full and when it's full it has to come
out somewhere and they call that a
spring that spring supplied water for
all the nature's critters plus from all
the families that live here and even
send water downstream to the city of
Austin
and what is it cost our governments and
governments all around the world they're
spending millions and millions of
dollars doing all kind of thing dams and
reservoirs and pipelines and all of this
can be done by you and I they don't have
to have government they can't expect
government to do it all anyway but if we
do have some contribution to ethics the
results from mind boggling I'm telling
you truthfully I've seen this property
and the experiences that people have
here change lives
Oh beautiful thank you so much what the
ceiling me when I was younger I
discovered in the Psalms the word Selah
it means to stop to pause to look around
you
and reflect on everything you see
[Music]
to me that's like Thoreau was to Walden
Pond gives us a chance to say what's my
duty as a Stewart of this ranch land and
I believe it's to take care of it and to
share it and if you don't share what you
have you're gonna live a lonely life
[Music]
that is a necessary ingredient for every
human being that we need to catch up and
live amongst mother nature and learn to
appreciate her for what she really is
I've given this land to a foundation it
will go on in perpetuity it'll never be
any different than you see it today when
I leave this world that's what I want as
part of my legacy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]